Today's topic.
Jubilee. What is a misconception people have about online.
Dating, but I think I'm open minded.
So I would love to learn just to see what kind of success that.
They had. Hey man, they brought in a dragon ballsy character for this episode.
Let's go. Let's go.
I'm Brittany. I'm 28. I'm a holistic healer and a yoga instructor.
I,
I am 24 and I am a director at
Jubilee. <laugh>.
Me and the dragon ball Z. Yeah, I got the, yeah.
Didn't he sound like he was buffering.
And I'm Kendra. I'm 27. I'm the casting producer.
Jubilee. Okay. Just off the top. I will give Jubilee credit for this video.
They don't, none of them seem detestable or really weird for no reason. Yes.
Sometimes I feel like they cast people that are very strange.
These guys all seem perfectly decent. Yeah.
Dating apps are all about.
I was a little hesitant to come up here cuz I, again, I think it,
it depends for certain people, but my generation,
a lot of people would just use it for hookups.
I was hesitant to come up here too, because I don't think it's all about,
but I do think it's mostly about,
I think it is harder to meet someone who was on there genuinely to like find a
connection and get to know someone who doesn't want that.
Because for me personally, um,
I wanna wait to have sex until marriage and I had a friend tell me I was too
wholesome.
And I was like, too, oh, I was too wholesome.
And that's why I wasn't getting any matches.
Cuz I wasn't like showing cleavage and I wasn't posting like there's trap
pictures. They wanted.
You to be more wholesome. Okay. Wholesome is fine.
But we know wholesome business.
Going out on dates. Normally with guys,
I would have just as much pressure as I would online. Yeah.
It's just go out from an online perspective.
That's not what I was looking for at the time.
But when I was looking for that at the time, online is an easy way to find it.
And this is just social media in general is that you can get away with doing,
oh yes. You know, you can be like, Hey babe, you know,
I wanna do this and this to you. You, I.
Mean, in my DMS every day we get like dozens of [inaudible], but
like unsolicited foreign, older gentlemen.
To be clear, go to parks and you'll get unsolicited.
This wasn't just born with the internet.
There's been people flashing folks for a long time. Absolutely.
This is just manifesting differently.
Now would I agree that online and the anonymity and the protection grants,
you more space to be a degenerate? Sure, sure, sure.
But it also grants people a lot of space to be Ford and to not be as shy.
I know a lot of women who could never approach on men in person,
but they could drop a DM. Yeah. So you gotta take the good with the bad.
You can't just talk about the bad aspect of it.
There's also the reality that some people are just too afraid to approach
others.
But I don't think just because it's online,
it's necessarily gonna lead to a more hookup culture.
Did you meet your boyfriend on? I did. I met him on Tinder. You did? Yes.
Did. Okay. Yeah. We've been going out for like four years now.
He lives over in Philadelphia and yeah,
I've never actually like gone on a date outside of a dating app.
So I don't know, based on the people I've met,
I don't really feel like there's ever been like an expectation that it's about
whoa.
It was so funny demeanor of the dude. It's not, it's nothing else. It's just,
it's just, it's how they dress though. He's a main character in watchdog. Yeah.
I know. I feel like I look at him and I just know he owns a skateboard. Yes.
A long board. Good precision. Okay.
So let's address the idea that it's only about good times in the bedroom. Uh,
I think it's like 25% of all relationships. I start online,
not something to acknowledge. A lot of people are choosing to meet online.
Why not in person? Well, there's a whole plethora of reasons. Women.
Sometimes don't like to be bothered when they're out in public.
Men are learning this right.
Men don't want to have to put their self-esteem on online.
So they're choosing to go online so they can maintain their dignity in a lot of
ways. Like I wouldn't even and know how to approach 'em well,
like not outside of online, I wouldn't even know. Yeah.
I wouldn't know how to approach someone. Yeah. I wouldn't, what am I gonna like?
Oh, I see. I'm gonna go to the gym. I see a girl that looks cute.
Am I gonna approach her? Mm-hmm <affirmative> absolutely not.
I see someone at the, in the bus. No in a club maybe,
maybe, but no, you know what I mean?
I wouldn't even know how to handle it,
but the idea that online dating is just for that is really, really not true.
And I think it also discounts the idea that a lot of people would never
otherwise meet without online dating.
How are you gonna meet someone who's completely removed from your social circle
and removed from your little sphere of friends of friends. It's hard,
especially if you don't like going to bars and clubs,
which a lot of people don't like, how are you gonna meet someone online?
Dating gives you an opportunity to meet people that are completely removed from
your reality.
Online, dating, perpetuates discrimination.
Here's what I suspect.
The black woman's gonna bring up the fact that she's black and that black people
and especially black women are heavily discriminated against online. Yep.
Statistically speaking, she's probably gonna be right.
This is what I suspect. She's gonna say.
And if that's the case and I don't say it perpetuates,
it's just a reflection of the discrimination that exists in reality. You know,
whether it's online dating or in person dating, you know,
there's that reality with black women,
even if it's not what I believe in how I value them. It's still there.
It's still there in reality. Well, you know, we're dealing with humans,
the same humans that are outside or on that app. So yeah, the.
Kind of discrimination that I'm thinking of is good.
Looks versus average looks.
Okay. You said looks. Yeah. And I completely agree with that.
A lot of times when I'm on apps, it's always based on looks first.
Like I'm not even reading your bio.
Or anything. And, but as you said in real life,
the first thing you're gonna see is not the brains of the person. What,
what do you like the most about me? Oh, I really like the way you, no,
that's not the, I don't know how you think.
The first thing I saw was your face was your shape,
shallow concur. But it still is what you see first.
You're filtering people out like that every single day as you're walking,
you're acknowledging people's attractiveness or not subconsciously.
And when you approach someone you've already subconsciously swiped right on them
based off their looks.
Can I say I'm taking this prompt from a racial standpoint, gang.
Come on, ride a train, a rally two, come on, ride a train, a rally.
You say O' rally it. What is it? Write it. Oh, okay.
Who's O' Riley. No, I always thought about like a rally,
you know like a pep rally <laugh> is what it made.
I feel like that's a song for pep rallies. Yeah. It could be.
There's a lot of racism and dating apps. And that is just the fact,
the founder of OK.
Cupid released a study back in 2014 where he made a graph and collected
people's preferences and it showed that black women and Asian men are the least
preferred on dating apps. What's her job.
She's a casting director for Jubilee. Yep.
That's the only time that I've seen Jubilee putting out, uh,
information that the, the contestant actually. Oh, you mean the stats?
The staff. I see you came with your little research or whatever, huh? Huh?
I see you came with your little research.
Can you please like,
gimme like a list of feminist advocacy organizations that have engaged in any
meaningful advocacy address those issues? Because they're actually none. Okay.
I know that you came with your little research or.
Whatever. I I've had guys when I was on DAP,
say the most disgusting things to me, like let's play dress up.
Like you're this play, but I'm the master. Or like I've never,
I've never dated black girl before,
or like you for black girl just microaggressions like that. And it's disgusting.
Lets.
Play sleep. And iron play master is not micro.
That is mega.
<Laugh>.
So I have the exact opposite opinion of
Kendra's where I feel like online dating has put me in front of
people that I wouldn't.
Normally. Then again, you are lighter than Kendra and that plays a fact.
Also attractiveness plays a effect. Yes. Always.
I'm not here to tell you that Kendra is or isn't attractive. I find attractive.
That being said amen.
As someone who's always thought of themselves as unattractive online dating is
not played in my favor. Just hasn't I understand. And so,
because of the fact that I have other qualities that made me endearing to the
opposite online dating, wasn't the best way for me to meet people.
And something that people have to acknowledge is that if you are not that hot,
you are not gonna have that high level of success. You're gonna,
and it's even worse for men. Yes.
Women have ease on online dating apps in that regards than men doing it's to
garnering attention. They did these numbers. I'll put the graph up for you guys,
but like hot women killed it.
Hot men did really well average men or like a little bit slightly above average
did okay. Hot women, like slightly worse did really well still.
And then it goes down and you see that like for men it's just harder to,
it goes down the rabbit hole real fast.
Most of those women are all applying for the same top level men.
And so that's where they're getting all their messages.
Whereas the bottom level men are just like free for all. Please look at me,
but what do you think.
About dating apps?
So dating apps like KCU and in the league have preferences in which you can
select race. Do you think they should be able to do that?
I don't think inherently there's a problem with an app,
like catering to what it thinks your preferences are because people wouldn't use
it.
If it didn't give them what they were like expecting to see or like wanting to
see.
I agree with him. Yeah. Yeah. I agree. It is the app. It's your preferences.
That's the job of the, the app. The person was like that. You understand? Yeah.
So yes. You're gonna have preferences.
The job of the app is giving you more option.
They're gonna give you more options in your preferences.
The person would've been like that in real life. Yeah.
I agree whether it's on the app or outside. So the app providing that, it,
it doesn't mean anything on the app. It's a match.
If you want to be match made with another trash human being,
the app should work towards them. <laugh> that's it? You know,
it's like someone brought up this thing. They're like,
I live beside somebody who is like,
doesn't like black people and it's bothering. I was like, well,
that's none of your business. They're allowed to have that view. If they want,
if you don't like it, you could move away. But they're entitle to hold the,
those views so long as they're not doing anything illegal,
they should be allowed to think what they think.
And if they want to date someone who thinks what they think,
that's none your business either. That's not. But anyways,
you don't like black people. You should date a black. That doesn't make sense.
I would also add it's better for them to add their racial preference so that you
don't end up matching with people who don't want to be with you because of your
race.
It's hard to tell someone that they're wrong for liking or disliking
a certain thing. Unless they're being like outwardly.
Hateful, this guy's like the anti Ben Shapiro,
you know like how Ben Shapiro speaks in triple time.
Mm-hmm <affirmative> this guy speaks. I like half speeds. <laugh> I?
But I understand. I mean maybe it's this way of being clear.
It's this way of thinking sometimes, you know, people,
they talk too fast and they stumble, you know? Yeah.
I used to be like that because I thought it was that's a side note,
but you know,
I thought that you look much more intelligent and you know about your stuff.
If you speak faster, I agree. But then again,
you stumble you're way of slowing down your speech sometime
you're gonna be able to think at the same time that you're talking. Yeah.
Therefore reflecting on what you're doing and what he said so far.
Been on point, even though it's been super slow. Yeah. It's been on point.
I can even hate the dude. Do you ever try to walk away? What do you mean?
But you stumble? No.
I only walk away if I was about to flame someone in my group
and I stumble and I cannot deliver the punch. So I just like, I,
you know what that. So you weren't trying to hide it. What? It's clear the what?
Like your life crumbles when, when they're not there,
what are you talking about? I just like, sometimes I feel like, you know,
goodbye and I choke <laugh>.
I was trying to say you <laugh> for the second time of the video.
If you don't take, take everything, take the chair, take, take the cam,
take your, your computer. Get the. Wait, when you are not here.
A good, bad answer.
Online dating makes it harder to commit to one person.
The answer to this one is an easy. Yes. Well,
no, it's not. I lied. It's not an easy, yes.
The answer of this is it depends on how many options you have,
whether it's online, dating, whether it's being a celebrity,
whether it's being the most popular dude in town,
whether it's being a girl who's really attractive someone who's rich, whatever.
When you have more options and more accessibility,
you will more likely than not be less. It there's more chances.
That's it. It's not about online dating specifically.
It's just about the accessibility aspect of it.
Now that's only available to people who are on the more attractive end of the
spectrum. If you're butt ugly, whether it's online, dating, offline, dating,
blah, blah, blah, or real life. Yeah.
So I've been with my current girlfriend for about a year
and we met on a dating app. I don't think it makes it harder to
stay committed, but I do feel like it probably makes it harder to,
um, decide on like the initial commitment.
There's a portion of time where we like still both had the dating apps
downloaded after we started like dating and it wasn't like considered
exclusive yet.
And there's just sort of this like thing in the air where it was like, well,
who's gonna like delete the apps.
First. This guy's the most assertive, low energy person I've ever seen.
I don't mind it. I like it.
His tone and his posture don't necessarily scream assertiveness,
but he's very clear with his opinion. He knows what he's saying,
but everything about his, his voice says lazy stoner. Yes. The stereotype.
Yes. But if you listen to what he's saying,
it's and I think that's why like the, the talking slow comes to like,
it comes handy. Sometimes.
I feel like I have a hard enough time picking my favorite flavor at the ice
cream store. You know what I mean? And then like, if,
if I were like day now and I met, you know, a guy online,
I would be like second guessing myself all the time. It's like, well,
what about that guy from two, two rows back.
<Laugh> I think they have a phenomenon for this. I think it's like the, uh,
the paradox of choice,
meaning it's not because people have more options that they actually make better
choices.
Sometimes having less options makes for more or makes her
better choices because you just commit to something and you stick to it.
So there is some truth to that idea.
What ask a girl what she wants to eat when you have two options.
<laugh> it's not because she got two options that she gonna be able to, to,
to choose abstract.
Barry Schwarz defined the paradox choice as the fact that in Western developed
societies,
a large amount of choices is commonly associated with welfare and freedom,
but too much choice causes the feeling of less happiness, less satisfaction,
and can even lead to paralysis. Now, to be fair,
I haven't read a whole bunch of studies that actually confirm this,
but it was an interesting concept. And I think something,
a lot of people can relate to. Yeah. Along the line of that. Yeah.
I normally narrow doubt my options to tune.
And then I flip a coin and I just move on my day.
It makes me so much easier when I don't know what to eat breath.
I'm just like you flip a coin heads or tails.
And then I just go with that mm-hmm but that's how I settle.
But when I choose something to eat,
it has to be aligned with what I want in my soul.
It has to be aligned with my Shara. And then that's just eat it, eat a sandwich.
There is someone out there for.
Everyone. No, no, I don't think there's someone for everyone.
There's some of y'all that's gonna stay.
There's gonna stay lonely forever.
And the reason for that is either there would've been someone for you,
but because of the way of thinking or some mm-hmm <affirmative>, you know,
times your type is the reason why you're alone. Ooh,
same sometimes the way that your stubbornness in believing in some things or the
construct that you have in your mind is the reason why you're like that your
stubbornness is sometimes the reason why you could be good looking and
everything and stuff. But sometimes you being shallow, you being stubborn,
you going for the same patterns is gonna be the reason why you're gonna stay
alone for the rest of your life. And it's not, if you want to change that fine,
if you don't don't, but sometimes there's some people that are gonna struggle.
And that's a fact, maybe you having those things, the struggle that you have,
the, the, the biases that you have, the, the, the, the,
the images that you have to think,
the pre received ideas that you have in your mind of people,
of relationship made you missed on that one person that was for you.
And it's not anymore. I don't believe in, uh, you know, aha is, you know,
people always ask me, like, they always ask me, oh, you, is that the, the,
the woman of your life I'll answer that question while I'll be dead.
Cause I'm still life. There's so much things that can change,
but I gotta be conscious of the things that are changing. You understand?
And there's a lot of people that are not conscious of all that. Yeah. So the,
it affects, it affects them, their dating abilities. So, yeah. So it is,
if you ask me if there's someone for everyone. Yes.
But it doesn't mean that just cuz there's someone for everyone that you're
likely to find that person is for you. Who said the same thing basically. Yeah.
But I just said it. Yeah. Yeah. But with less extra steps.
True. When I was, uh, 17 for seven years,
I wrote letters to my future husbands. I would just write about how I, you know,
like I can't wait to meet him. I can't wait to like spend Christmases together.
I, I would talk about the activities I couldn't wait to do with him. And like,
I actually was planning on like writing a letter until I met him and then giving
it to him like on our wedding night and the whole I'm so corny guys.
And uh, I actually,
I actually ended up ripping the journal up because, uh, I,
at the advice of a therapist,
they had told me that I am keeping him in these pages and preventing him from
manifesting in real life. And if I want him to come to me in real life,
like I can't keep him in these pages. And so I actually, why.
So why? When I was in high school,
I wrote everything down and then it all came to pass all of it
all, you know, all the things that I wrote down that were, are my.
Dreams. Cause Steve Harvey said it down. The scripture said,
if you have not, you have, did you write it down?
<laugh> did you, oh hell no.
Manifesting something you want is not a problem,
but also understand that what you want or what at you actually is best for you.
You may not know it. What I thought I wanted at 20 is not what I want at 30.
You're going to discover things. So going off this blind idea of like,
this is what I want and this is what I'm gonna get.
And this is necessarily the best thing may not be true.
Be patient with yourself.
You're going to learn and discover things for yourself.
But you just live off this rigid idea of what you think is good for you.
You may not have enough experience in life to know what that is.
How is an 18 year old going to know what her life partners supposed to be when
she hasn't even fully discovered herself? How does that make any sense?
So it just seems a little arrogant to me.
Like I wrote it down when I was a high schooler and that's maybe that worked for
you,
but for most people there's out a self development that has to happen before
they know what you want, baby. I got it.
Here's what I tell people online dating is not bad.
It can just be supplementary. It's like working out. It's a tool.
You take a protein shake afterwards. It's just a supplement. Is it necessary?
No, but you can add it to your regimen. It's just an auxiliary.
There's nothing that stops you from doing online,
dating and trying to meet people in person. So when I hear people complain,
oh my God, online, dating this all the just stop. You don't have to do it.
If you don't want to. You don't and are more people doing it more than before.
Yes. Good everyone. Get on it, enjoy it. It can be good for you.
But I think a lot of people,
and here's the thing a of people have bad to average dating lives and they
wanna blame it on everything but themselves or it's the world around me.
Men have changed. Women have changed. I wish I was born in a different era. Uh,
online dating is ruining everyone. No, you're just not good at it.
You're not good at it.
There's so many people who are happy and loving their dating experiences,
but you don't hear from them cuz they're too busy, being happy,
misery and miserable. People tend to be loud. That's the truth.
But to sit there and be like, oh my God, it's hard. And you want it to be easy.
A lot of people think they're old love. They think that they're old.
They perfect relationship. Do the people that are miserable either.
They're loud by saying they're loud or they're just loud.
You just see misery. And it's really loud. You know what I mean? You, you,
you see misery. They don't have to talk. That's just loud enough.
That being said, even if you do online dating or regular dating,
there's not one that's best than the other. All right. It really depends.
If you put the effort of it because doing online dating,
you're gonna have to do steps and do put efforts in after that same thing as,
uh, normal dating, right? If you take you talking about, uh,
training while the protein trait that you take, if you just take protein shake,
of course it's not gonna work. You need to get up and actually live some weight.
There's gonna be some steps that you're gonna need to do for that to work.
If you just do one and then let it there,
let it be there and don't do nothing about it. One is not gonna work.
The other is gonna is not gonna work either. So that's pretty much it. Yeah.
The guys, listen, not everything is for everyone. Ugly people.
Don't waste your time with all mind dating. I'll tell you,
look at other options cuz you may have other qualities.
That'll make you endearing to partners.
All I'm gonna look at are photos and you're not capable of having good. Good,
great photos. Don't waste your time.
It's what I tell ugly dudes every single day. Yep. It is what it is.
But for shy people who may be more attractive, it may be the perfect medium.
You may not have the courage to approach people in person,
but online day is how you meet your mate.
It works differently for different people.
So there is no one size fits all answer,
but I tell people having a couple more options,
isn't the worst thing in the world.
So that's pretty much my thoughts. Um, last note. Good,
good on Jubilee. This is a great video. Yeah, it was pretty good.
Everybody was actually level great cast, diverse opinions, even ones.
I didn't agree with. Talked about it respectfully. It was good.
And maybe it was the editing that was better. Who knows?
But that was a good video. They seemed likable from the jump.
So my point to this is good for you guys. We rag on you all the time,
but this was a good video. Hopefully you do more like this. Anything else?
No more crazy dumb people. Like honestly,
some of times you guys just do the too much.
Cause you're doing a disservice to the like the discussion that you're trying to
have is good,
but that you're doing a disservice to what it is to what it could have been.
That's right. But so if you enjoy this video,
make sure to leave a comment or like it helps us out with the algorithm.
Otherwise hit that sub button because I know 50% of you are not subscribing.
We said what? So hit that button. That's right. That's it hit it.